for an offensive foul the previous
possession this time
blows by gary trent jr attacks the point
howard can't get it to go james the
offensive rebound goes back up
fouled and one totally aggressive on the
offensive end making plays crashing the
offensive bullets putting his head down
and
look at that grown man strength the
ability to take the hit
and get the basket there's caruso
looking for a teammate he's found it
danny green open
shot won't fall rebound tipped howard to
davis
here's what i'm talking about turns the
corner i'm not trying to be a playmaker
for anybody right now
i'm putting myself in position to be a
scorer a terrific first half shooting
the ball well
james steps back another three you got
greatness on the floor
the competitive juicer says i'm not just
going to stand and take punches
anthony davis with the jump shot he's a
note in double figures now
slide looking to double team and
carmella unselfishly delivers the pass
anthony davis sees an opening goes
inside and the foul
aggressive move from davis russo and
anthony davis in the pick and roll
caruso sets the screen late rotation
grasping the basketball game right now
anthony davis outworking everybody on
the floor
the ability to get the basketball and
finish russo has given him
solid minutes on both sides of the floor
davis steps back knocks down another
anthony davis now
with 17 points 11 of them here in the
third looks absolutely gassed out there
right now
another alley-oop this time it's anthony
davis and terry stotz needs a timeout
the length of
la has impacted them james drives
and davis right there on the finish
james head down drives gets to the rim
bank shot is good
[Applause]
james for three bang lebron james from
downtown he's got 38
and the lead is 14. 38 point triple
double here in game three
[Applause]
got everything going tonight